all right good afternoon I'm Don Aaron
with the National Police Department we
want to give you a brief update this
afternoon as to what we know about the
Covenant Burgers on yesterday
there's one rumor going
there are those who think that specific
individuals who are targeted by the
shooter who entered the building on
Monday we have no evidence that
individuals who are specifically
targeted this school this church
building
was a target of the shooter but we have
no information at present to indicate
that the shooter was specifically
targeting any one of the six individuals
for a Mercury
Chief John Drake will now update you on
the
progress of the investigation overnight
and this morning including what we know
about the individual's purchases of
firearms over the past couple of years
again this will be a brief briefing
today
Chief John Gray
good afternoon everyone thank you again
for being here just a brief update of
what we know right now we've interviewed
the parents of uh Audrey Hale and we've
determined uh that Audrey evolved seven
firearms from five different local gun
stores here legally
uh they would legally purchase three of
those weapons were used yesterday uh
during these horrific tragedy uh that
happened
we know that they felt that she had one
weapon and that she sold it she was
under care doctor's care for an
emotional disorder uh law enforcement
knew nothing about the treatments he was
receiving but her parents felt that she
should not own weapons they were under
the impression that was when she sold
the one weapon that she did not own
anymore
as it turned out she had been hiding
several weapons within the house
we also don't have a motive at this time
we feel that these students that were
targeted for randomly targeted there was
not any particular student that they
were if she was looking for at the
confidence
and that's what we know as I speak and
we'll take any questions
Toyota Manifesto there's several
different writings about other locations
there were locations that was tells
about
the school there was a map of the school
a drawing of how potentially she would
enter and the salts that will take place
[Music]
I wear exactly
so that was spread out in different
locations when I went into the actual
Church the kids had already been
transported to the hospital also
with the adults I did see the head
School
person and she was in the hallways
and so on they were spread out when they
won coming there
if they were spread out you talked about
your response in terms of targeting
other building
there were some writings and a Manifesto
about other locations but but as far as
being an actor actual Target I can't
confirm that at this time can we talk
about your body cam footage
[Music]
she was in the hallway by herself there
was a confrontation I'm sure you could
tell the way
hallway there was the custodian
African-American and she shot through
the door to dinner she sprayed rounds
through the glass striking him you could
see
where where he came to rest as far as
the others they were just spread out in
different locations
I can't say it was a confrontation but
they were met she met the head person
right here thank you Chief you mentioned
the guns the multiple guns and that the
shooter was under the care of a doctor
is there any law in this state that
would have allowed police to take those
guns away from this person had been
reported if it had been reported there's
not a law for that but had it been
reported that she was suicidal or that
she was going to kill someone that had
been made known to us then we would have
tried to uh to get those weapons but as
it stands we had absolutely
no idea but actually who this person was
did she even existed Chief can you talk
a little bit about the time
so we know uh yesterday the Miss Hill
was leaving out of the residence she had
a red bag
they asked her what was in the red bag
and I think she gets dismissed it
because it was a motherly thing and I
didn't look in the back at the time she
didn't know that her daughter had any
weapons and didn't think any differently
if you didn't take most of the channel
so it's very traumatic keep watching the
body cam I think you will yeah could you
talk about the police response I know
they engaged the shooter pretty quickly
once they got to the school but can you
talk about the events that led up from
when they got the call
what time do they arrive at the school
and could you talk about that that time
because he hears about when we have 14
minutes or so yeah so they've got the
call at 10 13 about 10 24 they had
engaged the suspect as they arrived on
the property there were police cars been
hit by gunfire the suspect was in an
upper level
we believe there's been some training of
being able to shoot from a higher level
and her gunfire from the video I've seen
she stood away from the glass so she
wouldn't be an easy target to be shot
but as officers were
approaching the building that was
gunfire going on they went in they went
through
door by door as we clear buildings they
heard gunfire and immediately ran to
that and then took care of
this horrible situation and how long did
it take officers to actually get to the
school initially from when the first
call came in from the time it went out
from 10 13 to 10 24 it was over the
exact time of arrival time I'm not sure
I know that myself I ran emergency and
as I got there they were coming out
bloody and all kind of things were
happening so I barely missed being able
or being there to go in as well so it
was really quick the response and I
think you were next yeah Chico I was
just going to ask you about the two
officers whose body count we've seen
this morning uh had they ever been
placed in a situation like that before
to my knowledge I do not remember if
those two in particular have been in
that situation
officer Collazo has worked as a
paramedic with the SWAT team from so I'm
sure he's had some type of weapons
training I was really impressed that
with all that was going on the danger
that somebody took control and said
let's go let's go let's go and went in
and took care and just tried to end this
situation but as far as being in this
before I'm unsure you sir uh sir a
friend of the families is reporter in
front of the Hale families reportedly
said that Audrey was autistic can you
speak to that if you know if that's in
fact true I can't confirm that I've
heard that but I can't affirm that
that's true enough one more question one
more question that we're going to stop
um do you have any indication of the
significance of yesterday why the
shooter uh may have done this yesterday
and also do you have
um anything that could indicate whether
the school is targeted for religiously
have I can't confirm either I'm not sure
if that we're approaching a holy period
at Easter and all of that I can't
confirm any of that do not know
so we'll actually targeted that you take
the church we do know she was a student
at that uh at that church at one point
uh but unsure right now that was the
reason why I didn't find the questions
so I I felt today uh earlier
there
trying to decompress trying to make
sense of all of this I talked to uh
President Biden he's going to move down
and talk to him as well they're just
trying to do whatever they can with
their families and just kind of remove
themselves
thank you all very much thank you thank
you
[Music]
we evaluate each and every situation and
so part of one of my current schools is
we're always looking to be innovative
look at every single incident we have
and if there's a way to do better we
feel a response right now we I I'm from
what I've seen I don't have a particular
problem with it but we always want to
get better we're always going to get
there into a
so there's a lot of things that could
have happened traffic was dropped down
et cetera so but we're always looking